[Music]
on December 19 2018 a revolution started
to spread throughout Sudan
after Decades of living under President
Omar bashir's brutal military regime
civilians pushed back
they wanted a democracy in their country
a few months later this man and this man
helped take down Bashir in a coup and
then promised protesters the future they
had demanded four years later the same
two men are now at war with each other
tearing Sudan apart killing hundreds of
civilians
so how did Sudan go from this to this in
such a short time
and how did these two powerful men go
from Partners to enemies
[Music]
Sudan has a long history of coups
leader after leader has been brought
down by Military Officers the country's
official military now known as the
Sudanese armed forces or saf has held
tremendous power in the country for
nearly a century and they started using
that power soon after Sudan gained
independence from anglo-egyptian rule
Sudanese flag now replaced the flags of
those two Nations the first successful
military coup happened in 1958 Abdullah
Khalil a retired military officer and
sitting prime minister overthrew his own
civilian government to put Sudan under
military rule about a decade later
Colonel Jafar namairi carried out
another successful coup bringing down a
short-lived democracy then in 1985
namairi was out this military officer
took him down and later installed a new
democratic government four years later
Colonel Omar Bashir took down this
government and appointed himself as the
new head of state
but Bashir ended up being different from
those that came before him
given the pattern of military takeovers
Bashir knew he might suffer the same
fate as previous leaders so he used a
strategy called coup Roofing where he'd
surround himself with protectors but
would keep each one in check so they
couldn't overthrow him it started with
the staff throughout his regime Bashir
bolstered the Army and maintained a
strong relationship with them
he relied on them heavily to crack down
on an ongoing Civil War in southern
Sudan where saf and Allied militias
brutalized civilians on his command then
with the Army busy in the South Another
War started taking shape in the West
Darfur was in crisis
people here were historically neglected
lack of medical supplies and necessary
goods and little representation in
Sudan's governments left them feeling
agitated for years so in 2003 while
large portions of the army were tied up
in the South Rebel groups attacked
troops in this city in Darfur and Bashir
in recognizing that this rebellion was
taking place instead of relying on the
Sudan armed forces or staff the
conventional military he instead decided
to rely and arm local Arab militias in
the region that were known as the gender
lead this group was brutal and focused
on wiping out darfuri Rebels and
civilians at bashir's Direction
subtle imagery shows that the John
juweed is likely responsible for
destroying over 3 000 villages
troops in Darfur were responsible for
Destruction there as well
both groups are accused of mass killing
rape and the targeted displacement of
civilians
together they killed thousands of
darfuries
the events in Darfur showed Bashir how
to keep his power
and he turned to the genjiweed In Search
of another protector
among the johnjawide militias there were
a couple of men Bashir trusted and tried
to bring into the central government but
there is one particular John juic leader
that Bashir trusted the most Muhammad
hamdan de gallo or hametti
called him my protection particular play
on the Arabic word hemati which is my
protection versus hemeti which is his
nickname by 2011 the long and gruesome
Civil War here ended with South Sudan
gaining independence leaving Bashir in a
weak position
and soon after Sudan's economy tanked
many of the oil resources that sustained
the country were based in the South
which was no longer under bashir's
control to strengthen his power Bashir
give hemeti and the johnjaweed official
status as a pair of military force
called the rapid support forces or rsf
in 2013. at first the group was placed
under the niss Sudan's intelligence
agency also one of bashir's protectors
even though they were supporting the saf
in the ongoing war in Darfur
then in 2017 he passed the law placing
hemeti directly under his command making
it clear that the rsf's main purpose was
to protect him
to maintain the rsf's Loyalty Bashir
gave hametti Financial autonomy and
allowed him to take control of some of
darfur's gold mines smuggle weapons and
minerals into places like Chad and Libya
and send troops into war-torn regions in
exchange for money
at the same time Bashir continued to let
the staff have a hand in major
industries like weapon production and
Telecommunications while Bashir was busy
making these two forces richer civilians
continued to struggle Bridges broke out
in 2018 amid a really bad economic
crisis that's when Bashir faced his
biggest challenge
putting his protection scheme to the
test
the ultimate trigger was the
government's budget which allocated
about 60 to 70 percent to the security
sector which included bashir's
protectors while Sudanese people
struggled for basic needs
this led to the biggest revolution in
Sudan's history
[Music]
spontaneous protests broke out in
different parts of the country and then
they shifted to Khartoum in the capital
city Bashir refused to leave office the
rsf staff and other security sectors
backed him and crack down on the
protesters who ultimately wanted
democracy
but protesters didn't back down for
months and it became clear to the rsf
and staff that bashir's leadership
wouldn't be as useful to them anymore
so on April 11 2019 they made a move
that surprised civilians and bushir
staff commanders colluded with the rsf's
hemeti and removed Bashir from Power
oh
[Music]
protesters celebrated bashir's removal
but they didn't trust the men who made
it happen
a day after the coup
abdulphatahan a formal Regional
commander in Darfur took charge of the
staff together the two men gained
control of Sudan people saw them as
complicit in the violence in Darfur all
those years ago where they worked
together one as a member of the Sudan
Armed Forces one M as a militia leader
on the same side against large
proportions of the population of Darfur
and soon
on protesters
when pro-democracy protests kept
intensifying in karthum hameti and his
forces started cracking down on June 3rd
2019 the rsf killed over 100 people at a
sit-in protest and other massacres
continued throughout the country
after this these countries were forced
to step in to help put Sudan on a
democratic path the United States with
its Arab allies the United Kingdom
Ethiopia and the African Union pressure
Sudan's military and protesters to
accept a power sharing agreement in this
new deal representatives from both the
military and protesters would be part of
a transitional Council
in this plan the military would have
control for 21 months and civilians for
18. that meant the military would
eventually have to hand over power to
civilians to run the country the problem
was despite warnings from protesters
these two military men were put in
charge of the council with berhane as
chair and hemetia's vice chair
first the council acted in line with the
agreement and installed the new prime
minister Abdullah hamdak but after
multiple military interventions by these
leaders like a staged coup in October
2021 hamdak resigned in January 2022
that made berhan the de facto leader of
Sudan and hemeti as his number two again
foreign
Ty was never quite comfortable with
playing second fiddle especially because
he had amassed this fortune and had
positioned himself to play the role of
Statesmen almost better than bonhan
himself as berhan developed personal
alliances with leaders in the Middle
East Europe and Asia over the years
hametti did the same using his riches
from the gold mines to build
relationships with powerful individuals
in those countries as well after another
year of protests the U.S UAE Saudi
Arabia and the UK pressured berhan
hemeti and protesters to sign another
deal
on December 5th 2022 berhan hemeti and
political parties signed it promising a
new civilian-led transitional government
by April 2023 but these two men
disagreed on a key part of the deal the
rsf would need to become part of
burhan's army which would limit hemeti's
power
berhan wanted that to happen in two
years but hemeti proposed ten that this
agreement caused a big rift between
berhan and hemeti which led to the
current conflict between the two men
they've placed hundreds of thousands of
armed men across the country berhana and
his army have an Air Force that's
responsible for many of the casualties
and hametti's finances allow him to arm
more and more men on the ground hundreds
of civilians have been killed already
and thousands have fled Sudan ceasefires
have routinely been broken and talks
between the warring parties have gone
nowhere what was once a hopeful
revolution has been interrupted by these
two men
no matter who wins this war protesters
are left feeling betrayed by the
country's de facto leaders and also by
the International Community that claimed
to support their hopes for democracy
thank you
[Music]